so just jumping into this season
um Kevin obviously you've done some
stand up yourself in the past to say the
least uh was there ever a moment when
you would pitch you know to Amy uh hey
maybe moist should do uh some up on
stage stand up it thankfully never
crossed my mind
um I cherish my roots as a stand-up
comedian I continue to do it on occasion
um it's my favorite thing in life to do
but when given this opportunity to help
create and and bring to life this
ridiculous character of moish maisel I
just want to do that yeah I mean I would
offer my insights to Luke Kirby playing
Lenny Bruce or or obviously Rachel
playing Midge and you know there's such
great dramatic actors
that it was about
articulating and delivering and and
realizing
their scenes
right images monologues were completely
invented whereas a lot of times Lenny's
they were recapturing existing
monologues from his appearances
and you know it's all on the page there
and it's a great great opportunity but
challenge to make those words perfect so
the last thing I wanted to come in to do
was to come in and say you know the joke
really sits on this side not so much on
that side you know but I learned a lot
from Kevin and I felt like it was a
bonus of being his partner because he
knows so much about stand-up comedy and
they
Avail themselves of real stand-up
comedians as part of the narrative along
the way they weren't brand names that we
would necessarily know but Kevin would
say to me we were doing table reading
you know that was a real guy that guy
occupied this corner of this comedic
universe and so
I just had sort of like inside baseball
with him and it was really fun yeah and
then Amy Sherman palladino's father when
she was growing up was a stand-up
comedian so she lived in that world as a
child right and draws from it often and
wonderfully yeah I mean that's I I
didn't know that so that actually gives
a lot of insight into the show
um but Caroline so your Arc your
character's Arc this season I think is
just it's so it's so nice because
there's there's so many more dramatic
elements to her storyline this season
um did you enjoy exploring that side of
Shirley uh I'm not gonna spoil it but
specifically there are some moments with
her and her son and the potential of a
future but yeah I was longing for it you
know the thing about it is as an actor
you always want to play all the cards
you have in your hand and you never do
because what you are is a spoken wheel
and you want that wheel to turn and be
round and be robust but you as the actor
have so many more things that you want
to share and show so as the series went
on particularly the season when we would
get scripts and it would give me that
opportunity to crack Shirley open I was
thrilled by it really really thrilled by
it and grateful for it yeah I mean those
were some of the I mean those are very
emotional scenes I was like I was
holding tears watching them it was very
uh it was a lot it was a lot
um and you guys have had a great run
with this series
um
is it is there a specific aspect of this
show that you'll miss the most I knew we
were treated yeah we were very well I
mean I have to say again a lesson when
you treat people really well they bring
their a game to you it's and we were
so well treated so well respected they
wanted us to be and do our best yeah
that's not to be underestimated or or
mentioned that's a great one Caroline
and I I hadn't thought of that it's true
it's so true how we were how I have been
treated continuing to this very day yeah
right they really wanted to make it
possible for us to be 100
there in every way to serve the story I
mean the obvious answer is the the
scripts will never happen again writers
were never the genius will never happen
again the costume the Wardrobe building
will never happen again the
cinematography the the set design the
production design
casting the actors I mean every aspect
of it it is truly redonkulous every
department head is a true Savant
um so we're spoiled from beginning to
end but what a great singular takeaway
is how we were treated yeah I mean I
don't ever you don't ever hear that that
talked about a lot with with treatment
and how it how it feels to be you know
just a member of this group this project
you know
absolutely and we've all done a lot of
work during and
and since we've come down and as I said
to Amy when we got together for one of
these things and I've been working on
something else I went well you've ruined
every other job you've just ruined
everything for us yeah so that's kind of
I told Michael vegan
from day one
it'll never be this good and you're
really really screwed as a younger actor
this is the peak we've got maybe three
years
how do you have longer than that
so I'm curious because this is you know
there's so many characters on this show
and you guys primarily worked within the
maisel household the family was there a
specific character or someone that you
didn't have a scene with that you kind
of wished there was something
um for you to for you to engage Kirby
Luke Kirby for me for me it was Susie
yeah I wish I'd had a oh we had a couple
beats with her she came to one of the
family dinners for a second but I would
have liked to have had a very popular
Shirley and Susie Shirley and Susie have
something yeah you would have had some
problems with her yes exactly first of
all you know exactly I would have loved
to have worked with Alex more not only
because she's so terrific and was so
iconic and consequential on his show and
there was not a lot of story overlapping
between home and work so Mitch's whole
world of stand-up comedy was kind of on
the outskirts of where we were and I
always would you know we do these table
readings and hear about those days of
shooting and I always wanted to be there
yeah I mean it would have been great to
see you guys uh in your characters
watching you know Luke Kirby do his
stand-up as Lenny Bruce I think that
might have shocked um wish and surely a
little bit but it would have been
exactly why is he so angry he seems very
angry this young man look he's handsome
what's he have to be something I'm happy
about I don't know all the complaining a
lot of heckling in the crowd yes and a
free snap you're welcome
I was just I'm curious you know
obviously you guys have been in this
business for a while do you have any big
takeaways from this series from acting
in it you know beyond just the treatment
but do you have anything that you'll be
taking in into future projects yeah I
learned a lot about uh The Genius of the
eight page Runner Amy Sherman Palladino
um
and Jim McConkey are Steadicam operators
sort of in their own way
um
I don't say reinvented but but made it
their own and and reimagine what it
really means to do that I've directed a
couple of films and and I I really was
inspired by
the winner
um and what how challenging it is for
the actors
uh and rewarding when it's every piece
falls into place perfectly
um that was the big big big takeaway in
terms of of what I learned
um from this
I learned so many things I think um
Rachel had said once she got to see how
the sausage was made because she was
there every day I didn't quite get to
see how the sausage was made but because
a bunch of us come from the theater and
so we would rehearse and rehearse and
rehearse before we actually put it down
on film and I really thought
there is something really important
about that kind of work together before
you actually not that I necessarily will
get the opportunity to be in charge of
that I don't direct like Kevin does can
I be in your next movie of course okay
good phew
um that's on film now that's right I get
to do to that
I'd be in his next movie I know I was
around a lot of directors I mean it's
there's a lot of
multi-faceted talents within this group
in a sense and I think the other thing
that I really learned is
is you can take very small amounts of
material and you have to understand
where you fit into the story and how you
can contribute to the story in the best
way possible and when Kevin was joking
and said well I learned it's not all
about me but you know there's a very
famous acting joke when somebody's in A
Streetcar Named Desire and they say well
what character are you playing and they
ask them what the play is about and they
go it's about a flower seller because
that's the part they're playing that's
two lines at the end and I think one of
the things that I learned is is how to
contribute to the larger story
while telling your story it's a really
hard thing to do yeah yeah for sure I
mean I I feel like you guys bring so
much to the series and I really really
enjoyed seeing you guys in this uh in
this season especially um your story
lines with Joel I just I can't wait for
everybody to see this final season and I
want to thank you for speaking with me
thank you so much and enjoy your
beautiful apartment yes wherever you may
be I know it's I it's just it's a
delight to be here I'm just squatting
until you know they kick me out okay
stay there thank you for your interest
it's great I appreciate it thank you